- And the reason some people
don't enjoy their lives,
is because their container, their heart,
is contaminated with so many things.
Are you flying solo or do you
have a community of faith?
People flying with you watching over you,
encouraging you, inspiring you.
If you're always feeding
negative thoughts,
thinking I'll never get well,
I'll never meet the right person,
you're feeding doubt, feeding
mediocrity, feeding fear.
- Hello Believe Nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn from pastor
and New York Times best
selling author, Joel Osteen,
and my take on his Top 10
Rules for Success, Volume Two.
Rule number five is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
might win a prize as well,
and also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- It's easy to go through life holding on
to things that are weighing us down,
guilt, resentment, doubt, worry.
The problem is when we
allow these things in,
they're taking up space
for the good things
that should be there.
Imagine your life is like a container.
You were created to be filled with joy,
peace, confidence, creativity,
but if you allow worry in,
it pushes out the peace.
There's not space for both.
You can't go above 100%.
You have a limited amount of room.
If you allow guilt to take up space,
that's space that you don't have
for the confidence you need.
And the reason some people
don't enjoy their lives,
is because their container, their heart
is contaminated with so many things.
They have 10% worried,
stressed out over their job,
12% bitterness, mad at their neighbor,
20% guilt, beating themselves
up for past mistakes,
9% jealousy, their
co-worker is more beautiful.
They don't realize 70% of
their container is negative.
They wonder why they don't have joy,
creativity, passion, they only have room
for 30% of what they should have.
And the scripture says
give no place to the enemy.
It's not just talking
about forces of darkness,
that means give no place to guilt,
give no place to worry,
give no place to bitterness.
It can't come in and
automatically take over.
You control what's in your container.
You control what you think about,
what you choose to allow
in, and we all have
negative emotions, negative feelings.
You have to make the choice,
I'm not going to give
this jealousy, this bitterness, this anger
valuable space and let it poison my life.
I'm going to protect what I allow in me.
And every morning when we wake up,
we need to empty out anything
negative from the day before.
Somebody offended you at work,
they didn't treat you right,
it's easy to let that offense stay.
Feels good to carry around a grudge,
but you have to be disciplined, say no
I am giving this offense any room.
I am not going to let it sour my day.
They hurt you once, don't
let them continue to hurt you
by holding on to the offense.
Being offended is not harming
them, it's harming you.
It's taking up space you
need for the good things
that move you towards your destiny.
Take inventory of what
you're giving space to.
Life is too short to go through it
with negative things holding us down.
There's a large company
that has a slogan that says,
That was easy.
A few years ago a friend of mine
sent me their big red button
when you push it says,
- [Button] That was easy.
(audience laughs)
- I keep this by my bathroom
sink there on the counter.
Every so often, I reach
over and push this button.
I like to get that
phrase down in my spirit.
'Cause it's easy to go through life,
looking at our problems,
focused on our obstacles,
thinking aw man, this is goin' be so hard.
I dread dealing with this,
it's never going to work out.
That mindset is not only stealing our joy,
but it's keeping us
from seeing God's favor.
When my dad went to be with the Lord and
I first started ministering,
it took everything I had
to write a message for that weekend,
all my focus, my creativity, my energy.
I was pressured, stressed.
When I finally finished I felt like
that's the last one that I could ever do.
And if I wasn't careful,
I was tempted to dread it
and think this is too hard,
I'm not going to know what to
say, I can't do this anymore.
I had to turn it around.
Father thank you that your yolk is easy.
Thank you that I'm well able,
thank you that you've
equipped me and empowered me.
I got my mind going in
the right direction.
I went through seasons
of struggle, strain,
difficulty, but I didn't let it
become permanent in my thinking.
One day I came into
this anointing of ease.
What once was a struggle,
is not a struggle anymore.
Every week when I finish a message,
I hit this button,
- [Button] That was easy.
- just to remind me that it was easy.
Quit telling yourself, this is so hard,
I'll never accomplish my dreams,
I'll never get out of debt.
This is a new day.
It's easy to do life on our own,
and think we don't need any help,
but you won't reach your
highest potential by yourself.
God has ordained people
to come into your life
to strengthen you, to encourage you,
to push you towards your purpose.
You've seen birds that fly in formation.
When geese make that V, it takes
40% less energy for them to fly.
They could do it by themselves,
but they understand this principle
they won't go as far if they fly solo.
Are you flying solo or do you
have a community of faith?
People flying with you, watching over you,
encouraging you, inspiring you.
After the football game the other night,
the star running back
was being interviewed
and he'd had a great game, set a record
for the amount of yards he had rushed.
The reporter asked him how he did it.
The first thing he said was
it was because of my offensive line.
Those guys that block
for me, they're the best.
And my coaches have poured
into me and made me better.
My trainers have helped
me to get stronger.
He recognized that we need each other.
You can be good by yourself,
but you can't be great by yourself.
You won't become all
you were created to be
without the right people around you.
You can go 60% but when
you get in formation,
when you have a family of
faith blocking for you,
praying for you, encouraging
you, you'll go 40% further.
Too often, we base our value
on how someone is treating
us or how successful we are
or how perfect of a life we've lived.
The problem is all of
those things can change.
If you're getting your value
out of how people treat you,
then if they hurt, they disappoint you,
you're going to feel devalued.
If you're basing your value
off of your achievements,
how much you make, what you drive,
the title behind your name,
then if something happens
and you don't have that position,
your business goes down,
then your value will go down.
And some people don't
feel good about themselves
'cause they've made mistakes in life.
They're not where they
thought they would be.
Now they're living
insecure, feeling inferior,
they're basing their value
on their performance.
How someone treats you
doesn't change your value.
What they say or do
doesn't lessen who you are.
Mistakes you've made
doesn't decrease your value.
That's what you did,
that's not who you are.
You can buy a bigger
house, drive a better car,
but that doesn't make
you any more valuable.
That increases your net
worth, not your self worth.
You were already valuable when
you had the small apartment
and no title behind your name.
That position may give you more influence,
but not more value.
You can be a stay at home
mom, raising your children.
You may not have the influence of the CEO,
but you have the same value.
Value is not based on what you do,
what you make, who you
know, that's superficial,
those things can change.
The enemy works overtime
trying to devalue us.
He'd love for you to go through life
letting what people say
make you feel inferior.
Comparing your life to somebody else's,
thinking you'll feel good about yourself
when you catch up to them.
When you live in that neighborhood.
Or when you perform perfectly,
when you break the addiction,
then you'll feel valuable.
But nothing you do will
make you any more valuable.
Nothing you achieve, nothing you overcome,
you are valuable right now.
God calls you a masterpiece,
you are one of a kind.
You didn't come off an assembly line,
you weren't massed produced.
God made you unique, there
will never be another you.
Put your shoulders back,
start carrying yourself with confidence.
You have been fearfully
and wonderfully made.
We may not realize it, but
we're always feeding ourselves.
What we watch and listen
to, the people we're around
the thoughts we're dwelling on,
that's feeding our inner man.
If you go to lunch with people,
that talk bad about the boss,
make fun of a co-worker,
put down a friend, they're
feeding you gossip,
feeding you jealousy,
feeding you disrespect.
Here's the key, whatever
you feed, is going to grow.
You may not like what they're feeding you,
you're a nice person, but if you continue
to hang around them, before long,
you'll be gossiping, you'll be critical,
you'll be disrespectful, why?
Because you kept feeding the wrong things.
If you're always feeding
negative thoughts,
thinking I'll never get well,
I'll never meet the right person,
you're feeding doubt, feeding
mediocrity, feeding fear.
A man told me how he
spent years of his life
on drugs and alcohol and
it had ruined his marriage.
He wasn't there for his children.
Now he was so down on
himself, so discouraged.
What was he doing?
Feeding the guilt, feeding
the regret, feeding the blame.
If you feed guilt, it's
going to get bigger.
If you feed fear, it's
going to become larger.
What if you spent that same energy
feeding your faith, feeding
your hopes, feeding your dreams.
What are you allowing in your spirit?
The people you're spending time with,
the thoughts you're dwelling on all day,
is that inspiring you,
building your faith,
pushing you towards your dreams?
Or is it junk food, feeding
you guilt, mediocrity,
negativity, causing you to compromise.
A friend of mine was diagnosed
with a serious illness.
The doctor put him on a very strict diet.
He couldn't eat any sugar, any flour,
any meat, it was only raw vegetables,
nuts, grains, very limited.
Now I asked him if he was going to do it.
He said, what do mean am I going to do it?
I don't have a choice,
my life depends on it.
Today I'm putting you on a new diet.
Not physically, but for your inner man.
No more junk food.
No more dwelling on thoughts of worry,
fear, I don't have what it takes.
No more hanging around
people that are feeding you
negativity, causing you to compromise.
No more guilt, condemnation,
I'm all washed up.
You're prescription is for faith food.
Feed your hopes, feed your dreams,
feed your confidence, feed your destiny.
It's easy to have faith.
It's easy to believe for your dreams,
but faith without patience
can get you into trouble.
What you're believing for may be
taking longer than you thought.
You're not making progress, not
seeing a dream come to pass,
but God knows what he's doing.
Don't try to force things to happen,
you don't have to promote
yourself, manipulate people,
convince them to like you.
Yes we should be determined,
but you don't have to beat down a door.
At the right time, things
will fall into place.
At the right time, the
right people will show up.
Now do your part and wait
for the promise to unfold.
You're not falling behind,
you're not being left out,
you're right on schedule.
When we've been believing for
our dreams to come to pass
for a long time or
problems to turn around and
we don't see anything happening,
we're not making progress,
we're not getting good breaks,
it's easy to lose our passion
and not expect things to change.
It's been that way so long,
we start accepting it.
I'll never get well, I'll
never break this addiction.
I'll never accomplish my goals.
I tried, I prayed, I believed,
but it didn't work out.
That may have been true in the past,
but I believe you are
entering into a new season.
You're coming in to a high time.
High time is when things
suddenly change in your favor.
High time is when
blessings chase you down.
You don't have to go after
them, they come after you.
High time is when you're healing shows up.
You meet the right person,
you break the addiction.
God makes things happen that
you couldn't make happen.
Now if you're going to see this high time,
there's something you have to
do, wake up out of your sleep.
That means get your passion back.
Start believing again, start
expecting things to change,
start talking like it's going to happen.
You can't sleep through your
high time and see God's favor.
You can't be complacent
and step into the fullness
of what God has in store.
The amplified version
says, it's a critical time.
It stresses the importance of the season.
It's saying, don't take it lightly,
don't dismiss and say aw,
this isn't for me today.
If you don't stir your faith up,
you can miss the new
things God wants to do.
What you're believing for is
not way off in the distance,
it's close, it's at hand,
it could happen today.
Live with this expectancy.
There has to be an
anticipation in your spirit,
that today could be my day.
Too many people go around
feeling wrong on the inside.
They don't really like who they are.
They focus on their faults, weaknesses.
They're constantly critical
towards themselves.
That recording of everything
they've done wrong
is always playing in their mind.
You're impatient, you
blew your diet yesterday.
You lost your temper,
you're still struggling
with that addiction.
You should be ashamed of yourself.
They wonder why they're not happy,
it's because they have this
war going on, on the inside.
But you're not supposed to go through life
feeling wrong about yourself.
Quit focusing on your faults.
Quit over-analyzing your weaknesses.
Quit beating yourself
up because you're not
where you thought you would be.
You may have some weaknesses, we all do.
There may be some areas where you know
you need to improve, but
being down on yourself
is not going to help you do better.
Having that nagging feeling, telling you
you don't measure up,
God's not pleased with you,
you'll never get it right.
It's not going to help you move forward.
You have to accept yourself
right where you are, faults and all.
One of the biggest challenges we all face
is getting along with people
because everyone is different.
We have different personalities,
different temperaments,
we come from different backgrounds.
When somebody doesn't agree with us or
they do something we don't like,
it's easy to get in conflict with them,
argue, try to straighten
them out, prove our point.
Before long, we're at
odds, mad at each other,
living offended, there's
stress, tension in the home.
What's happened, we've allowed strife in.
Strife is a spirit, just
like peace is a spirit.
You've walked into a place before,
you don't know anybody,
you've never been there,
but you can feel the tension in the room.
In the atmosphere there's stress, discord,
nobody said anything, but you
know something is not right.
That's the spirit of strife.
Now if we would see it
as the destructive force
that it is, we would be more careful
about allowing it in our lives.
After all, it's easy to argue,
especially with those closest to you.
Let's be real, your spouse
can get on your nerves.
You love the man, you
can't live without him,
sometimes you feel like choking him.
A reporter asked Billy Graham
if he'd ever thought about divorce.
He divorce no, but murder, yes.
(audience laughs)
But when we let our guard down and
say things that are hurtful,
disrespectful, demeaning, that's not only
damaging the relationship,
that's opening the door to strife.
That's inviting that destructive
spirit into our life.
That's why the scripture says
give no place to the enemy.
Strife can't just come in when it wants,
bring division, disharmony,
tear relationships apart.
We have to open the door.
And I'm not saying that we
should never have an argument,
never say a wrong word,
that's not reality.
But when it comes a part of who we are,
it becomes common, we're
constantly arguing,
fighting, being disrespectful,
that means we've gone way too far.
It's easy to let the pressures
of life weigh us down.
We have traffic to deal
with, bills to pay,
people that are rude.
If we're not careful, we'll look up and
we don't smile as much,
we're not as friendly,
we never laugh, never have fun anymore.
We have too much pressure,
too much responsibility to enjoy life,
but God didn't create you
to live with a heaviness.
You're not supposed to go around solemn,
serious all the time,
burdened down by problems.
Taking time to laugh, to have fun,
that re-energizes you, it
helps keep you in balance.
If it's all work, all stress,
all dealing with problems,
that's going to weigh you down.
You can get so busy raising your children,
changing diapers, getting them to school,
making sure their homework is done
that you don't enjoy your children.
It's all work, no time for play.
And sometimes, we think
we have to be serious
to show that we're responsible.
But you can be responsible
and good natured
at the same time.
Have you let the pressures
of life weigh you down?
Are you always solemn, always serious?
If you don't make this adjustment,
not only will you not enjoy your life
to the full, but you won't
have good relationships.
Nobody wants to be around
a grumpy, sour person.
That pushes people away.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Pagla Bye asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile
next, check out the link
in the description and you
can go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know what clip resonated
the most with you, what
lesson are you going to take
with this video and
immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow, leave it down
in the comments below, I'm really curious
to find out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Surge Wisdom.
Surge Wisdom thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and making multiple videos
on your YouTube channel
covering all the different
chapters in my book.
Thank you so much man for the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
(light music)
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
much love, I'll see you soon.
(boom and jet sound)
- But living guilty doesn't
do anything productive.
It doesn't help you to do better,
it causes you to struggle more.
Guilt drains you emotionally, physically
it will wear you out.
When we're guilty, we don't pursue dreams,
we don't believe to overcome
challenges, we get stuck.
This is why the enemy works
overtime in this area.
He knows guilt will keep
you from your destiny.
There's nothing he would love any more
than for you to go through
life against yourself,
focused on your failures,
feeling unworthy.
You can't drag yesterday's failures
into today and live in victory.
Let it go.
God's mercies are fresh every morning.
Don't spend another
minute down on yourself,
living in regrets.
When those voices remind you
of everything you're not,
one of the best things you
can say is I am righteous,
I am holy, I am blameless, I am honorable.
Everything in your mind
will say, no you're not.
You have an addiction, you keep giving in
to the temptation, you
made those mistakes.
But when you declare I am righteous,
you are announcing to every force
that's trying to stop you.
You're announcing to the accuser,
to the guilt, to the heaviness,
you don't control my
life, you don't determine
my destiny, you can't stop my purpose.
The creator of the
universe made me righteous.